[Music]
let's go to becca in seattle home of
pearl jam and allison change what's up
becca
hi how are you partying what about you
i'm good thanks for talking to me again
of course uh yes hey this is the second
time the last caller called about a year
ago or however many months ago and we
got another repeat call this is
fantastic so what's up
um so the last time we talked we were i
was just before
deployment number one with my daughter
and now we are knee deep in deployment
number two oh no
it's okay we uh we learned a lot from
the first one and it's completely
different and nothing that happened in
the first one applies to the second one
it's like having kids man it's like i
got this figured out like nope
right um
so she my daughter is three um and she's
a nut
and she's absolutely great she
holds on so tight um
to everything and everyone um especially
me
and so i feel like i'm kind of
sorry i'll get to my question um so how
do i no no no no no no no that was
important what were you gonna say you
feel like what
i feel like um
i'm kind of at the end of my rope yep
sort of
i'm
so tired um
i'm so tired and this actually has to do
with that um and so i uh
so how do i create boundaries with my
three-year-old without weaponizing our
relationship or making my presence
a punishment for her specifically at
bedtime oh that's so good
you are using my words against me and i
love it
i love it
yeah in the car you know i listen to
your stuff and i love it and so i heard
that and that like it keeps rattling
around in my brain because i'm trying to
transition her into doing
bigger girl others not big girl things
but like bigger kid things and being a
little bit more independent and our days
are great like i work full time and so
she goes to a daycare where she loves it
she's so happy her teachers are amazing
they they know every transition we have
great communication with them we come
home we go to the park we have dinner we
read books we do bath time and then
bedtime comes
and she just looks at me with those big
brown eyes that i gave her and she's
like don't leave me yes and i'm like
dude
and i i don't know if i lost whatever
mom jean i was supposed to have because
i can't
do like co-sleeping i will be awake all
night it scares me her room is her safe
place and so for her to be in my room
and like she's gonna fall off the bed
and she's gonna crawl off the bed and
climb on a dresser like i i don't sleep
when she's in my room
and so we've been doing this since she's
three and i've been the only person
getting up to get her
and so i can't remember the last time i
slept through the night which is not a
big i feel like this is a very common
parent thing but i
because i've been doing that now i feel
like i
i'm not a super emotional person and i
just break down crying because i'm so
tired
yes
and then i
my default reaction is kind of anger and
i've worked really hard in my life to
not do that and to go towards other
things and to like take a second and and
not do that and now i feel like i'm i
don't even realize how angry i am until
my brain comes around to realizing how
mad i am and i'm like i'm not
i'm i feel like i'm behind yeah
oh man i would
if your husband wouldn't kill me i would
hug you if you were sitting right here
um
i haven't
i know he does i know he does um
i have a couple of let me write these
down because i'm afraid we're gonna um
okay
man
number one
let's let's pretend there was no
deployment
three o'clock i mean three-year-old and
bedtimes
is the worst okay
so you've got 20 things happening all at
the same time hear me say this i have a
smile on my face you're doing a great
job
okay and you didn't just hear the last
call where we get we're yelling at each
other you are doing a great job okay
and the chaos you feel and the this is
never gonna end
all of that is i mean i couldn't tell
you how normal it is okay yeah
um it doesn't help but it doesn't make
it like oh cool we're all struggling
with expensive beef that doesn't make us
less hungry but it makes us feel less
crazy okay yeah
the two words i heard you say i mean i
heard you say one word a lot and then
another word just kept coming to me okay
um and that sounded all woo like i have
a word spoken to like not like that
um and and
feel free to push back on anything okay
okay you said i feel i feel i feel i
feel i feel a lot okay yeah here's a
crazy thing that happens when it comes
to feeling a lot
is
your kid
can quickly become our emotional
regulation blanket
i feel better i'll just use me i feel
better when i'm hugging my six-year-old
daughter
when i'm watching some knuckleheaded
little movie whatever kid nonsense they
want to watch about dinosaurs and
dragons i don't the crap are watching i
lit my heart rate will slow down and
i've tracked it on like a wrist strap
when she snuggles up next to me for
about 20 or 30 minutes
and
intuitively she feels that
yeah
and so the more
exhausted and spun out you get this is a
crazy thing
the more she can feel like i have to be
near her to help
i've noticed that she's last month she
started getting really angry
and i was like this is it's and i know
why like i and i've listened i know
she's a sponge and she picks up
everything
and so and especially because it's just
her and i and so i'm the person that
she's getting all this from and so
that's why now i'm like
well she's she's she's slowly developing
her own too right it's this weird mix
here's the other word that keeps coming
to mind to me tell me i'm wrong
you sound really really tired you sound
really exhausted you sound really burned
out can i tell you what you really sound
sure you sound completely and totally
alone
you sound really lonely
yeah
is that true
yeah
i imagine you're working all day and
she's a daycare and you want to make
sure that i've got to do both parent
roles
so i've got to spend extra time at the
park at dinner having fun reading books
singing songs doing bath and then right
i've got to make sure all that time is
accounted for be otherwise my daughter
will fall off because husband's gone and
this is what moms do and we got to do
this we gotta do this
your daughter would benefit tremendously
if one night a week you got a babysitter
that she loved
or
sent her to a friend's house a parent
another parent and you went hung out
with some girlfriends and just hung out
she would benefit so much
but she's already gone all day it
doesn't matter
i know but but you're coming you're
coming home
with a hole in your heart
and part of that hole is your husband
fear but you're coming in with a hole in
your heart which is connected to
connectivity to a tribe
your body recognizes you are all alone
it's a very normal response
and yet
you feel this guilt and obligation to do
every minute of every day with her that
she's not a daycare because i'm such a
terrible mom that i send her today kit
right so all this
guilt factory
i'll push up i will push against on that
because
like i love having she has a place to go
she has friends she is she's not upset
when she goes so i'll push against that
i don't feel guilt for sending her to
daycare okay like in that specific
scenario good but i do feel guilt if she
comes home and she sees me and she's so
excited to be with me and then i like
push her off on someone else i don't
want her to feel like i don't want her
around gosh because she's i like her
she's great she's right three she's
little like she's i'm not gonna i'm not
that person that's my three-year-old my
best friend
but she's not her best friend good um
she knows she needs to see you have a
best friend
oh
yeah
and we need a model that we need to we
here's what we need to do for her
we need to let her off the hook that
it's her job to hold center of this home
because she's just three she's not
strong enough to hold that center
so once a week we're gonna let her know
no mom goes to
mom's going out with her friends you've
been playing with your friends all day
now mommy's gonna go play with her
friends
and she may be like no mommy no
for the first few times and then it's
gonna become the way it is
mommy goes and plays with her friends
and then what we're gonna teach that
three-year-old is man having a community
was so important
that once a week mom left her kid to go
to be with community because the only
way she could fully parent
was to be fully tailored to some to a
gang
that's the only way it works
is that fair
yeah and that's really really hard
yeah
because that means mom's gonna have to
go be awkward and be weird and show up
and be the new girl and the news
i know it's the worst
and so we let our kids be our excuse and
we let netflix bear excuse and we let
our workout program be excuse we have
dude i'm the king of excuses
the king read
too many books i like to read yep
for real did you know i made a rule for
myself here's how the rule i made
um i go to all these great cities all
over the country doing events and things
and you know what i do i sit in the
hotel and read books like a loser like a
complete nerd and so this summer i made
a rule
when i go to a new city i gotta go walk
around
and so the rule i made is i have to get
a new tattoo in every city that makes me
go to a place that i'm gonna be
uncomfortable with people i don't know
and i have to spend a lot of time just
talking to people in awkward situations
and the last town i was in we're in san
jose i got a tattoos with kelly and
joanna and uh we're doing some media
there and i had the way i was all
splayed out i looked like i was getting
a proctology it was not comfortable and
i was just getting a tattoo on my arm
but it was not anyway you know i hung
out with a bunch of dudes there's this
rad
awesome gangster dude getting a tattoo
on his neck and we were talking it was
all i got to meet all these people
i had to just put myself in that
situation and then when i did it was fun
right it was fun and then i had to
explain to my daughter like dad why are
you keep drawing on yourself right all
that all that's part but i have to go
out and do those things i know the
science i know the reality of it and i
got to make myself do it and that's
where you are okay now when it comes to
the sleeping thing
this is world war ii no this is world
war seven eight nine and ten the
co-sleeping not co-sleeping should we
should we not you even said i guess i
lost my mom gene no you're not failing
as a mom if you want a full night's
sleep okay you're not you don't hate
your kids because you need sleep that's
like saying i can't take a full breath
because i want my kid to have more
oxygen in the room it's not at work
okay so how it works
um and some parents
they're they're some kids
are
just do better when they are co-sleeping
um there was some seasons we did that
there were some seasons that we
forced our kids into their room they
couldn't like you will be in your room
then there were some seasons we set up a
pallet on the floor
because i'm like you if somebody's in my
bed it's a weird thing but i just set up
some like made a blanket bed on the
floor and in the middle of the night you
can come in
if you wake me up you are choosing to
never come into my room again i'm going
to lock my door
but if you come in here and you get into
your special bed you can do that
but don't don't wake me up if you choose
to wake me up then you're choosing to
not come in here anymore
yeah you see what i'm saying or
um tonight is sleep night for mommy and
so you're gonna have to stay in here
tonight you're sleeping in here the more
your child
doesn't feel like
they are keeping you together
the more they can begin to practice
sleeping
yeah that makes sense yeah um
can i tell you this go ahead no go ahead
go ahead go ahead
um i
we've i've
we've had to do a lot of transitions
with her and so even just like finally
we're at the place where i can hang out
in her room for a couple minutes we have
a set amount of time she's got this
little thing that plays audio books and
so i stay for one chapter and then mommy
goes and has stuff to do and so she's
okay she doesn't cry she's like okay
like once those chapters over she's like
bye mom go do your stuff and i'm like
all right cool and so i get out and do
my stuff and then at like midnight one
o'clock she's awake and her eyes are
open and she's like mommy why did you
leave me and i'm like all right
um
okay hold on we got to
i'm gonna tell you something i just told
the caller before
we don't let three-year-olds buy beer we
don't let three-year-olds smoke
so three-year-olds are gonna wake up and
say stupid three-year-old things
you didn't abandon your daughter you
didn't leave her
she just asked you a dumb question that
just bangs right on that mommy cord
right
i know and then i'm like well is it dumb
because no her dad is in here
like it's not and then
and then like she john you don't
understand like she
when when people visit like my sister
came to visit this summer and she was
here for a couple days and then for a
week my daughter was asking why auntie
left her
and so it's not it's like it's not just
me and it's not my husband's everyone
like anyone who comes into her life
she hopes i'm so tired hey hold on she's
three
i know that i don't want her to feel
that
here's what she's feeling she's just
learning how relationships work
and some relationships are here all the
time
and some people come and then they go
and then some jobs you have
there's extended periods of time where
we're gone
and there's gonna be extended periods of
time where they're home
and so when she asks hard questions you
have to remember she's three and the
only relationship picture she has is to
her teacher to a couple of knuckleheaded
three-year-old friends and to her mom to
her dad
right
and so she has a picture of a
relationship with mom where mom always
stays
aunt susan looks just like mom cool aunt
susan's gonna stay forever whoa and
susan left after a week
yeah why did she leave why did she leave
why did she leave it's not it's not it's
not her pointing out
it's not like i asked kelly every day
why are you drinking again why are you
drinking
she does it she discovered a face she
doesn't drink at all
but like it's not like i'm like hey why
didn't you do this why don't you like
that's
that is like i'm i as an adult i'm
asking that question because there's
like a performance issue or like uh yeah
a three-year-old's just trying to figure
out the boundaries of the world
yeah it's up to it's up to you as an
adult to choose to not internalize that
as some sort of performance metric that
says you're failing because you're not
you're doing so good
so good
and when she says the more matter of
fact you can answer those questions the
better
because she will be like a sponge for
your responses
okay so when she says mommy why did you
leave say because mommy needs to sleep
and then i'm on to my next thing and if
you need to go in your room and shut the
door and then cry be like i'm the worst
one go do that but do it
take that from her
so that when she asks these questions
she's just trying to figure out the
boundaries why did aunt kim leave why
did aunt susan leave why did whoever
leave cause she's got her own home and
she has to go home and sleep in her bed
and but she's slept in our bedroom yeah
this is our guest room and she's slept
in our guest room but her home is there
and that's where her friends are and her
family is and that's where her food is
in her fridge and so she had to go home
that's where her puppy is and that's
where she's got to go home
and you can say you know be a gift i
really miss her when she goes
just like i miss daddy
it's sad when people we love leave huh
yeah it is
and now we're on to the next thing you
want to go watch a show you want to go
play you can go to the park right so now
we're into the next thing and i know
she's i know it's it feels so nuclear
and she's three and let me say it again
becca you are doing such a good job
such a good job
such a good job such a good job
don't equate every one of her questions
and every one of her concerns and every
one of her behavioral issues with i have
to make up because dad's gone
they're not all related some may be
amplified some may be exacerbated but
they're not all related all
three-year-olds ask we used to have to
tell my son
um
he used to say
everyone gets someone to sleep with but
me
he was actually right and it kind of
broke my heart because he's like i sleep
all by myself there's nobody in here and
i was like ah this is the worst he's
three and both of us stayed there okay
you are doing a great great great great
job
great job and
dude
thank you for listening to the show i'm
so glad that you're with us call back
soon and hey i want to talk to this
husband of yours when he gets back i'd
love you all to both call and i'd love
to hear how you all are going to redo
re-entry after a second deployment thank
you for your service thank kim for that
and thank that little three-year-old
girl for her service too i love her